as many of you have heard me say many
times there's so much mythology
surrounding the making of jeans movies
particularly an American in Paris and
singing in the rain so I always say
don't go to a Wikipedia don't go on IMDB
don't believe anything that's on the
Internet just call me and go on Gene
Kelly the legacy on Facebook and I'll
answer your questions but I thought I
thought I'd start to dismantle some of
the myths tonight number one there is no
milk in the water that have any of you
heard that before
they say it's it's printed everywhere
that they put milk in the water so that
you could see the raindrops so that they
would be illuminated no it's actually
terrific cinematography and lighting and
Jeanne said it was really really
difficult and the way he explained it to
me was he said imagine if you go to a
ballgame and you're in the park and it
starts to rain and if you look down at
the field you don't see the raindrops
but if you tilt your head back you see
the light the raindrops backlit by the
light in the stadium now the challenge
they had for those of you who've seen
this movie is there anybody who has not
seen this well good for you I didn't
know who Gene Kelly was when I met him
so you're we're in the same boat and
they all kept talking about this thing
called singing in the rain that was to
die for I had no idea what that was so
so don't feel bad if you haven't seen it
so so the challenge you'll see as Jean
particularly is dancing along in front
of the plate-glass windows they had to
backlight that rain but make it so that
you don't see that lighting equipment
reflected in that glass and they also
had to make sure that Jean was lit from
the front and it was very very tricky
and in the production notes you'll see
that many tapes had to be redone because
they would catch a bit of the equipment
in the glass
another little myth you will often hear
that Debbie Reynolds that Jean did not
want Debbie Reynolds in the movie Jean
absolutely wanted Debbie Reynolds in the
movie it was Arthur
preed who ran a little piece of film
he brought jean up to his office and he
ran a little piece of abbadabba whoo
whoo with Carlton carpenter and Debbie
Reynolds too and he thought she was
perfect for the role and Jean said he
thought so too and they brought Stanley
Donnan up and Stanley Donna's comment
was yeah but can she dance and Jane said
it doesn't matter if she can't dance
because he had trained so many young
people in those schools in Pittsburgh
and Johnstown that he knew that you
could train make a non dancer look like
a pro and that's what he did he always
caught you choreograph to the lesser
dancers so he did want her in that it is
true that Jean was very very sick when
he shot the iconic singing in the rain
number he did have a temperature of
about a hundred and three and that
number was shot in a day and a half and
what he would do now you have to
remember he's behind the camera he's in
front of the camera he's behind the
camera I went on the road for the 60th
anniversary of sing in the rain with the
great rita moreno you'll see her in this
as zelda it's the great line with Jean
gets to deliver like you're a real pal
Zelda and Rita does not have a large
part in this picture but she said that
she went to the set every day just to
watch it being filmed because it was so
exciting to watch it but she said Jean
was in constant motion it he would be
behind the camera setting the camera
shot setting lights then he would jump
down in front of the camera change into
costume shoot the number and then what
he would do this is all shot on the
Culver City lot they draped the the
stage with black tarpaulin and hung
rigging for the water and it would pour
down and after he did the take he would
go outside of the tarpaulin and lie on
the sidewalk and bake the fever out of
him and then go back in and do do more
it is Jean always said to me that he
felt that Jean Hagen was the real glue
that kept this picture together that
made this picture she was nominated for
an Academy Award but lost to Gloria
Grahame
Jeanne always felt that Donald O'Connor
was one of the greatest unsung heroes he
really thought he was one of the the
real true artists and one of the
greatest improvisational comedians of
all time and the the number that he does
with the dummy came out of the between
shots there's so much time that passes
and Donald would just sit and entertain
all of jeans assistants he would pick up
things that were on the set and make
them laugh and then they'd they'd come
in the next day and they'd say Donald do
that thing that you did yesterday and he
had no recollection of what he did so
Jean had his assistants Carol Haney and
Jeanne Coyne who went on to be the
second mrs. Kelly and right down I'm
known as the third and final one write
down everything that Donald did and then
Jean strung it together and they added
the ending to that and Derek is correct
they did have to bring the brother in so
that they could build his confidence
again